you've had so many incredible moments in
your career if you could go back and
talk to your younger self what what
advice would you give you it sounds like
you know psych 101 but I would say try
to be in your body you know try to take
it all in because sometimes I think we
especially artists we're not able to
even take a compliment you know it's
it's difficult to ever feel like you're
good enough or you're yeah well I just
accept now that I'm older you know I
have a much different relationship to my
career than I did when I was younger and
definitely since I've had cancer and
since I have my children right
everything's changed but when you're
when you're young you feel like you're
in this huge you know you're like with
all the other salmon swimming upstream
and trying to you know make your mark
and I'm watching what a lot of these
young girls are doing now in videos
trying to like notice me notice me when
at the end of the day I just want to say
it's your voice that brings you
authenticity that makes you memorable
you know it won't be what you did in
your videos or what you're doing on
social media it will be the impact that
you how do you make people feel how you
make people feel yeah yeah for sure you
talked about and there's an article that
I was reading it you're talking about in
your your album in 2013 that it was very
hard to break into country music you
recently signed with big machine that
celebrates a lot of country music
artists right do you feel that that will
be more helpful moving forward or how do
you do you feel any differently than you
did maybe perhaps when I read that
article yeah I wouldn't you know part of
my relationship to the country format
was the self promotion that you have to
do where you go and do a lot of guitar
pools and you do a lot of free gigs
hoping that you'll get played and
usually you might get played maybe once
because that's what you were saying it's
not that easy to get played on country
especially if you're a woman and
especially if you're an outsider right
and that was all fine and good
but you know what signing with big
machine now this record is sort of not
formattable it's there are a lot of
different lanes that it kind of works in
there are a lot of different styles of
music mm-hmm and the reason I loved
Scott and and big machine is that he had
such a vision for each song you know not
just let's just got a country format or
whatever it's different now than it used
to be it's very different now but
technology and with playlists you know
it's not like that's one of the reasons
that this will be my last album me you
don't I'm sorry what did you say yes I'm
a this is my last album what do you mean
no well I'm not gonna quit making music
yeah but just the tradition of making a
full body of work like an artistic
statement yeah in this day and age with
technology being as it is and with
streaming services when I record now at
iTunes you know okay
people make playlists and they cherry
pick songs there and you can spend a lot
of time and money and emotion making it
a full artistic statement and people
more than likely will never hear it like
that okay so I like it you do the
journey yes I like the idea now is
making putting out songs and not waiting
for a full artistic statement to be
completed mm-hmm and you know they
aren't working everything done when you
know that it's nothing you heard that
way anyway that makes sense
so I also read somewhere where you were
talking about some of your your masters
being wound in fire what does that do to
an artist I mean there's so much talk
now about owning your own owning your
own masters and all of these things what
was that like hearing about that oh yeah
I mean it makes you heart sick you know
it's not it's not just the songs that
came out it's every take of that song
and it's the songs that didn't come out
and it's the dialogue in between I mean
for me
what's more disheartening than my some
of my stuff going is the
you know it's the history of our music
that was in there from the Allman
Brothers to all the way back to Billie
Holiday to Eddy Holly and it that is
those are the hieroglyphics of this
period of our humanity you know but you
know what do you do what do you think of
the push of women owning more of their
own music not just women but men too
I think everyone should be on our music
it's just you know the way the system
was in the beginning and I don't know
how it will continue to be particularly
a lot of the fires when you're a young
artist and you have nothing and a label
says we believe in you and we want to
see you be a big artist but in in but
will will pay for the recordings that we
own the recording yeah and you know
that's generally the way it is words now
with people making records in their
studios your basements on their
computers there's not really a reason to
ever let your masters be owned by anyone
you know so I don't know if that's and
also nowadays people don't go to tape so
they just go you know onto some kind of
digital format yeah it is very different
you talk about sort of just where you
are in your life and with your kids your
kids were in Glastonbury with you right
they were sitting on the stage they were
working over there bringing guitars out
oh that's amazing yes that's good
getting paid what is it like well that's
good yeah what's it like having them on
the road is it easier is it harder it's
great I mean they've they've always been
on the road with me I mean I don't go on
the road without them I'm their mom yeah
I'm a single mom and they've grown up in
tour buses they they love sleeping in
monks I mean they love this lifestyle a
little too much probably they love it
and we're enjoying it up until a time
when they won't want to do it and
obviously have a 12 year old who will be
a teenager so at some point and he's
probably at some point gonna be like I
want to stay with my friends you know
but as of right now they love it you
know and it's it's a great life you know
I have a great band they have a lot of
constant
and auntie's and you built a village
right
we they'll take the village to raise a
lamb we're like gypsies you know if I
get to go and see Stonehenge you can go
science museums and water parks and yeah
that's the best summer can be yeah yeah
we do everything together and nice so
it's nice
that's amazing so if do any of them show
any inkling of getting into the business
do you see and would you yeah would you
be good for that yeah I mean my my hope
is that they they find joy in something
and that that can make a living for them
you know a music it's hard to make a
little music now you know people don't
buy records and streaming definitely
doesn't pay enough to for an artist to
live but my 12 year old plays stand-up
bass in the symphony MA and he wants
he's like mom he was playing mom I want
to play bass because you're a bass
player and when I get to be 19 I want to
be in your band and I was like and then
then I start thinking the last person
you're gonna want to play with when
you're 19 is your mom and then my my
nine-year-old is he's more into sports
Thanks I will say he's musical too
amazing
well thank you for stopping by
congratulations on everything thank you
really great having me thank you